-Happy Thanksgiving to you.
Nice to see you.
-Thank you so much.
Nice to see you, too.
-Thanks for coming on.
Thanksgiving exciting for you?
Not exciting? Do you have
a big family gathering?
-No, not exciting.
Not exciting, no.
-No, not exciting?
-No, no.
So, I come from a family of --
of vegetarians and vegans,
and, um -- Yeah, yeah, I mean --
And, I mean, all due res--
You know.
And, um, yeah.
-Yeah, so --
-Yeah, so, no, we do, like,
a "Thanks-living,"
which is, you know --
which is, like, a pun.
Which is not fun
in and of itself,
but also when it applies
to a vegan Thanksgiving.
-Thanks-living.
-Thanks-living. Yeah, so we --
-What happens at Thanks-living?
-We -- we -- You know,
we buy a turkey, which is
essentially saving a turkey.
And we put that picture of the
turkey, you know, on the table,
instead of turkey food,
you know.
And it says little things like,
you know,
"Oh, it's Bagel, and he likes
to run around and..."
You know, and stuff like that.
And so anyway,
then we don't eat turkey,
but we do feel the guilt
of it anyway.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You see -- You're looking
at Bagel the whole evening.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And talking about
how he likes to run around
and other activities
that a turkey does.
-It gets worse. Yeah.
Yeah, no, so, like, my sister
will read from this book,
"Eating Animals"
by Jonathan Safran Foer.
-Oh, my goodness!
-I don't know if you've read
this book, but it's basically --
It takes you through
the factory farming process.
So I'm sitting there
eating asparagus.
I've already committed
to what you've wanted. Yeah.
-What foods do you eat
besides asparagus?
-They make loaves. Loaves.
Everything goes into a loaf.
You have lentil loaf.
Loaves.
-Lentil loaf.
-Oh. Like a non-meat loaf.
-That's it. Sweet potato loaf.
Anything that you probably
don't want to eat,
they turn into a loaf,
and then we have to sit there
and eat it, yeah.
-Loaves-giving, yeah.
Thanks-living. Alright.
Well, that's good.
Do you cook at all?
-No, I don't cook. I don't cook.
Which is probably, you know,
why I wound up going
to a Thanks-living
every year 'cause --
I should be taking control
of my life.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, no, this is good.
I think you'll have
a fun -- a fun time.
I want to talk about
"Fleishman Is in Trouble."
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
You are Fleishman.
-Yeah. That's right.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-It's great. It's smart.
It's funny. It's very New York.
You and Claire Danes...
-Yeah.
-...who I love. Have you
ever worked with Claire?
-No, no. I mean, it was amazing.
We -- I did meet her once.
I met her probably,
like, 15 years ago.
I -- She has
no recollection of it,
which is the impression
I normally make on people.
But especially --
especially in this case.
-When did you meet Claire Danes?
-So, my wife had to go to some
benefit, and I was with her.
And I had to go with her.
And I just got really high
because I --
I knew it was
going to be boring.
And then --
[ Laughter ]
And I -- I got, you know --
I got separated from her there.
You know, and I wound up
talking to this woman.
And she -- We had gone
to the same high school,
and she said she was an actress,
and she went to Yale.
And I was just thinking,
"My God.
This is, like,
the coolest person
I've ever met in my life."
And I -- I told her that.
And then, I walked over
to my wife, and I said,
"Honey, I think
I just met my soulmate.
I met this amazing woman."
And I pointed to the woman
who I wanted to be my soulmate,
and Anna, my wife, she said,
"That's Claire Danes,
you idiot. Good luck."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Were you --
Were you married to your wife?
-I wasn't married to her,
but things were going well.
-You were dating her
at the time.
-I was dating her, yeah.
You know, we did a dry run.
[ Laughter ]
-Now you're happily married.
And all these years later,
here you are working
with Claire Danes.
-Yeah, but she had
no recollection
of the greatest day of my life.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
For this series,
you told me backstage
that there was something
they asked you to do
you were a little
apprehensive about.
-Yes, yes.
-Can we talk about it?
I think it'll be good
to talk about it.
-Yeah. I mean, I'm apprehensive
about most things.
But in particular, they wanted
me to be naked in this.
You know,
they wanted me to be naked.
Not -- Not my front.
You all know what --
Everybody knows
what the difference is.
-Sure.
-And so -- But my back.
And I'm, not, like -- I'm not
a very comfortable person naked.
You know?
-No.
-No, I mean, I would shower
in a bathing suit if it meant,
you know, staying --
if it wasn't unsanitary.
-Of course. Yeah, of course.
-Just so I don't have to see
anything. You know what I mean?
And I also have, you know,
the same body -- For the last,
really, 30 years,
I've had the same body.
And so um -- And, yeah --
But anyway,
they wanted me to be naked.
-So you're not parading around
saying,
"Hey, this is the way I live."
-I have three more jokes
about my body.
No, yeah, yeah. Sorry.
So, anyway, they wanted me to
be naked, and I was mortified.
You know, and I thought,
"Okay, well let me --"
They asked me so, so nicely.
And I thought "Okay,
well let me call my wife,
'cause she'll say no,
and then I can say,
'You know, my wife said no.'"
So, I called my wife,
and she said,
"Well, is the woman
in the scene naked?"
And I said, "Yes."
And she said, "Well, then
obviously you have to be naked."
I was like, "I was calling you
'cause I thought
you would say no."
-"You're my excuse out of this."
-Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Anyway, she --
she had already hung up.
So I --
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, so,
I was naked in the show.
I was, you know --
-Wow.
-It was deeply shameful.
-Yeah.
Did it change anything for you?
Did it feel like, "Wow"?
Like you've -- I don't know.
-No, no, I didn't feel like,
oh, I conquered anything.
-Yeah. That's what
I meant to say. Yeah.
-It was more like,
oh, I just did this thing
that I'm embarrassed by,
but then when it comes out,
I'm gonna be doubly embarrassed
by it, you know?
-At Thanks-living,
do you not bring up the show?
-You know, I told my parents
that there was no premiere
in New York.
[ Laughter ]
I said, "I think they're just
gonna go to air with this one."
-"They're just gonna go straight
to Hulu on this one," yeah.
-Yeah, "I don't think
you have Hulu."
And then I'm gonna disable it
on their TV.
-Oh, my gosh.
-They're not going to know.
-Can we set up what "Fleishman
Is in Trouble" is about?
It's a great novel, by the way.
It's a good read, as well.
-Yes, yes, yes. It's by --
I guess you're a fan of
Taffy Brodesser-Akner.
The writer. She's a genius.
-I love her. She's so great
and funny and smart.
And it's a great book.
-And more importantly,
you're in the show.
You're in
"Fleishman Is in Trouble."
-I do full frontal nudity
in this.
I didn't want to do it at first,
but I called my wife --
-She was like,
"Is Jesse doing back?"
-"Is Jesse doing back?"
-"If Jesse does back,
you gotta do front."
-You gotta be fair. Exactly.
-Yeah, you gotta see both sides
of what a man looks like.
-Of course, you do, yeah.
I'm not sure if people will
understand when they see
my front, but it's alright.
-Exactly. They'll probably
think it's my back.
But anyway -- No, yeah, so the
show is about this couple --
-You're saying my front
looks like your back?
-I'm just -- Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very funny.
-Oh, thanks.
-That's very, very funny.
How do we set up the show?
Sorry.
-Oh, yeah, the show is,
you know, about this --
Oh, I'm not -- It's not true.
-No, no, no, it's not.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, the show is about, like,
a couple divorcing.
They're going through, like,
a bad divorce.
And then she drops the kids off
with me and disappears,
and no one knows where she is.
-Yeah.
-Alright. I want to show a clip.
[ Laughter ]
Here's Jesse Eisenberg
and Claire Danes
in "Fleishman Is in Trouble."
Take a look at this.
-No, actually, I'm just
asking a question, Toby.
It's an honest question.
-Can I get Instagram?
Everyone has it.
-No, we've answered this before.
No social media until you're 13.
-Everyone.
-Hannah, you don't
even have a phone.
It's not good
for kids and anxiety.
Your brain is still developing,
alright?
-Dad and I will talk about it.
-Excuse me.
We've already talked
about it, okay?
-How about my anxiety
that everybody is always on it
and leaving me out?!
-She has a point.
-Yeah?
[ Thud, water running ]
-You're an animal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
Throwing raw chicken.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, raw chicken.
-Jesse Eisenberg, everybody.
Check out
"Fleishman Is in Trouble."
It's great. Right now on Hulu.
Madelyn Cline joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.